hello everyone I thought we'd continue
with another game from the 1959
candidates tournament now in my previous
video you've seen a game between Bobby
Fischer and so it was a legal reach were
she doesn't really make a mistake or
anything he just makes a series of very
small inaccuracies and in the end the
Fischer's attack prevails so I decided
to show you a game that was if there
wasn't for the towel game that won the
brilliancy prize this game could may
well wonder brilliant surprising if
they're ones wasn't for the towel game
against miss love now I think this is
the third video on making with sweat oh
sorry glitch the first one was that
bughouse game I believe where neither
player captured any pieces the second
one was his loss against Bobby Fischer
and this is his third game he's playing
the former world champion vasily smyslov
and i didn't really introduce glitch
properly in any of my videos and he's
quite an interesting guy so a couple of
words about him now he was born in 1923
he was born in Belgrade in Serbia and he
was born into a poor family
they say he started playing chess at the
age of eleven and since he didn't he
couldn't really afford a chess set
he made his own chess pieces from the
course of wine bottles and but by having
that kind of a start he he already
became a Belgrade chess champion of the
Belgrade the Chess Club
at the age of 15 and already at the age
of 16 he became an international master
now he qualified for the candidates
tournament three times and although he
didn't win any of the candidates
tournaments I mean such is the fate of
great players who leave who live in the
era of Legends but in his successful
career he managed to defeat six world
champions six world champions like
smacks ooh Mikhail Botvinnik vasily
smyslov Tigran Petrosian he defeated
Michael tall and Bobby Fischer so a lot
of great great champions felt hurt this
led to the legal rich so not bad for
someone who started playing chess when
he was 11
made his own pieces out of corpse of
wine bottles not like for example Fisher
who started playing when he was 6 or
Michael tile who I believe he started
playing when he was 4 so I mean he was a
it was a spectacular player but you know
like like many others Karis Bronstein
they just they just didn't stand a
chance because they they lived in the
wrong era I believe it was Mikhail
Botvinnik the that said after he saw a
game between Fischer and tall that it
will be Fischer and tile for the next 15
to 20 years decided the fate of the
World Chess Championship and if you know
Todd took care of his helped a bit more
and if Bobby wasn't Bobby Mikhail
Botvinnik would probably be right but
that being said let's get back to this
game and it's quite a quite an
unthinkable game because like I said we
have former world champion vasily
smyslov with the white pieces so that's
like that's like if you hear that you
don't think he will even lose yeah
something like that
so let's see the game Smith law opens
with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 and g6
by so it was ugly good each now he goes
for the Kings Indian defense and this is
no wonder because our other than he was
such a great player he was also well
known for his contributions to theory in
the real opus and especially in the
Kings Indian defense so g6 we have
Knight to c3 and the Bishop to g7 and
here we have Bishop to g5 this is thus
missile variation of the Kings Indian
defense so Smith's love goes for it
we have c5 and here a normal response by
white would be something like d5 and
after d6 probably 4 but after this c5 by
Leo rich Smith Slav plays D captures on
c5 here we have 90 to a6 going after the
c5 pawn g3 Knight captures and Bishop to
G to d6 by legal rich and wrote to c1
getting broke out of that a 1 5 a 1 file
as the bishop is eyeing it
developing a rook so all is well castles
by Glico rich and before now kicking the
night away from that mighty sea v square
nine three six attacking the bishop a
bishop goes back Bishop d2 and now a
five a three a captor some before a
captor some before and night the D for
now and here you have to finish your
development with the white ended the
game goes on probably best idea first
missile would be something like Knight
to f3 and after captures captures Bishop
to e6 attacking the c4 pawn and after
something like Bishop captures and b7
rugby 8th Bishop to d5 now captures and
before Bishop captures pawn captures and
night to b5 this opens up the attack on
the rook but after something like Queen
to e8 a queen to a8 going for the h1
rook
here's missile could castle and have to
remove like rugby to its it's a better
position for black but after that D
captures and c5 really didn't really
didn't have a way of getting an
advantage with white so he would
probably have to go into something like
this black is definitely better his dark
square Bishop is a monster here rook is
very active on b2 Queen is very active
on a8 this rock is ready to jump into
the game so this would be better for
black but it would be playable but after
night the D force missile decided to
play Knight to h3 here we have Bishop to
e6 in leverage now develops a piece and
goes for the c4 pawn Knight to d5 Knight
captures we have pawn captures attacking
the bishop and Bishop to d7 and here it
looks like Smith's log is ready now to
castle and then probably improve the
position of this weird knight on h3
the problem is if you castle here for
example castles
you get Bishop to a4 and as weird as it
sounds this actually loses the game for
white your queen is attacked you have
nowhere to go with the Queen other than
a one but then comes Knight to C 2 and
here you have to give up the exchange
with rook captures and Bishop captures
if you don't if you play play Queen
d1 then black can win the exchange by
playing nice d3 opening up the attack on
the Queen and also attacking the rook on
f1 but he doesn't have to do it
immediately
first he can grab the pawn Knight
capture some before again attacking the
Queen Queen e1 and I come back comes
back to c2 and again you don't have to
give up the exchange or play Queen d1
but now comes 93 again opening up an
attack on the Queen and after the Queen
moves now Knight captures and Bishop
captures and here black being the
exchange up having a powerful Bishop
repair and and the past beep on this
would be a completely winning position
for black so after this Bishop to d7
move Smith Slav doesn't want to Castle
he plays rook the c3 and he does it so
the Queen doesn't get trapped the Queen
can now enter the game here we have rook
to a2 and again this stops castling if
you cancel now you get Bishop captures
on h3 the bishop characters and now
comes Knight captures any - with check
this comes with a check and an attack on
the rook and c3 so after you capture
with the Queen now comes the Bishop
captures on c3 and the bishop on d2 is
pinned the rookies on a two x-raying the
Queen and e2 so again you lose the game
so after rook to a to Smith's left-right
Queen to be one now attacking the rook
on a to the queen is now in the game he
can bring the rook back and maybe safely
Castle them but the problem is now Glico
rich plays Queen to a8 and now you have
you have a lot of trouble here as the
rook is defended also look to a1 is a
terrible threat winning the Queen here
rook to c1 was played this is the
strongest move for smith avez it stops
rook to a-1 but you don't really you
don't really you don't really stand a
chance here anymore because here ugly
Girish played Bishop to f5 and it was in
this position
this is move 18 that former world
champion vasily smyslov resigned the
game why did he resign the game well
first of all the Queen has nowhere to go
b2 is covered by the rook b3 is covered
by the night the queen is attacked by
the Bishop from f5 if you block it
with efore you simply get Bishop
captures on h3 Bishop captures and now
Knight to f3 check if you go
King f1 Knight capture some d2 checks
the King wins the Queen sorry wins the
Queen if you play Kings to D 1 you get
rook captures on b2 and this is
checkmate and lastly if you play King to
e2 you get
Knight character some d2 not only losing
a piece but the Queen on b1 is attacked
after the Queen moves now comes Knight
to b3 with a discovered check from the
rook also the rockin c1 is attacked and
if you block that you get rook captures
with Czech Queen captures night before
forking the king and queen this is
completely crushing on the other hand
after Bishop to a5 if you decide to
block with something like Bishop to e4
of course you can all see this simply
Bishop captures on a three wins the full
piece slicing all the way to f1 that the
King has to stay in the center the rook
is useless here so white wouldn't have
any compensation whatsoever if he
decided to play a game like this
so after this Bishop v Smith Slav
probably in in disgust and disbelief
resigned the game and he immediately
left but when the crowd saw this as
there were show boards where the moves
were being displayed there were 2,000
people in the crowd and they were making
so much noise
they were roaring that none of the
players that were still playing their
games could continue their games because
there was too much distraction so they
asked gligar rich if he could please
leave the stage as you know people were
cheering so much for him so if you left
the stage you know things settled down
and the other players were able to
continue their games but legalish
himself said that he was not happy about
winning this game he was very happy
about the feeling vasily smyslov but he
knew what it meant for him he was a
soviet he lost with the white pieces and
it wouldn't be so terrible if he lost to
a soviet player in 18 moves while having
the white pieces but losing against the
non-soviet player lee Girish knew
very well what that meant for smyslov so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I did prepare a nice photo
for you this is AG licorice playing
against vasily smyslov although this is
this isn't a game their game from 1959
this is their game from 1969 the there
was no photo taken of them playing in
this tournament because the game ended
so fast probably the photographer didn't
even manage to do one photo but if it
exists I couldn't find one so so instead
that here is a nice photo of two of them
playing although they are ten years
older here and another thing I wanted to
show you for a couple of videos now
featuring this tournament the 1959
candidates and black Belgrade and Zagreb
I wanted to show you the final standings
of the tournament but I always forget so
these are the final standings as you can
see Tom won the tournament one and a
half point ahead of Paul Harris and we
have a Tigran Martin which Petrosyan in
third place 4th vasily smyslov and the
sweaters are illegal each year in fifth
place so he didn't have a spectacular
tournament but again he did place better
than young Bobby Fischer 33 Collison and
Paul Banco and of course we can see how
we can all see who the most solid player
of the tournament was different her tan
which Petrosyan of course with 17 draws
and only four losses but you know if a
couple of those draws ended in a win you
know the standings could be quite
different but we can see the that tall
and Kara's definitely crushed the field
with 16 wins tall in 15 wins carries it
was a race all the way to the end all
the way to the final round
as I believe Tom only needed a draw in
the final round to win the tournament so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I do hope you enjoyed the
meeting svetozar Glico rich and I will
probably continue with this tournament
as well I mean it's I always say that
the game is from a famous tournament but
what can I do every tournament is famous
so you know there are a lot of a lot of
cool games to cover and
I will continue covering them so yeah I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Christopher berry for a
contribution to my channel think a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon
one other thing I didn't I didn't have
time to make the Q&A video but I will
probably make it after Friday and said
on Saturday probably so I've seen a lot
of you posted some questions and thank
you all for that I will definitely have
a lot of material for this video so I do
hope to to finish it around Saturday so
yeah thank you all I will see you soon